[Musique]
la 11e édition de la fête de la nature
se poursuit en ce troisième jour la
découverte du piton montvert un espace
naturel sensible ancien volcan basé sur
le massif du piton de la fournaise
l'occasion pour les participants de
découvrir les différentes espèces
endémiques grâce à tommy guide sur ce
site et à prix de vente est une espèce
d'orchidée différentes sur le site
déjà ça c'est ça sensibiliser les gens
sur ce qu'il faut faire ou ne pas faire
en forêt là à prendre les armes
endémique qui assure le site pour qu'il
puisse se reconnaître plus tard dans une
prochaine discussion dit corinne
laurence mussard a souhaité participer à
la visite accompagnée de ses deux filles
une initiative appréciée par cette mère
de famille soucieuse d'inculquer à ses
enfants les bons gestes
il nous apprend à reconnaître les
espèces à protéger
et puis celles qui sont invasive qu'il
faut enlever donc comme ça on fait la
différence c'est que les enfants balades
n'arrache pas tout est simple lesquels
il faut laisser dans les sentiers pour
le département propriétaire de 95% des
forêts de la réunion la fête de la
nature est devenu un rendez vous
incontournable
en fait j'ai un moment avec l'ensemble
des réunionnais afin de le sensibiliser
sur la préservation de la biodiversité
et les richesses que nous avons qui nous
entourent et qui ne peut nous apporter
de notre quotidien des services et des
prestations que l'on soupçonne même pas
au total ce sont près de 80 animations
pédagogiques qui sont proposées aux
quatre coins de l'île
plus que deux jours pour profiter de
cette fête de la nature
[Musique]